[Musik]
der letzte Reaktor steht still die Zeit
des Atomstroms in Deutschland sie ist
vorbei jetzt startet hier ein
gigantisches Projekt der Rückbau wie
sicher ist das es ist einfach wahnsinnig
aufwendig gäbe ist noch ein zurück das
Thema ist durch normalerweise kommt man
da hinter mir nicht rein aber der
Betreiber die EnBW hat ausgewählte
Medien zu einer presseführung eingeladen
wir werden die letzten Brennstäbe und
die jetzt ruhende Turbine sehen es ist
ein Besuch mit Auflagen wir werden nicht
alles filmen dürfen und mehrere dieser
Sicherheitsschleusen passieren müssen
wir sind auf dem Weg zum Reaktorgebäude
von Block 2 des Atomkraftwerks in
Neckarwestheim seit dem 15 April wird
dort kein Strom mehr produziert
in fünf Stunden ist es soweit die
letzten drei Atomkraftwerke gehen vom
Netz nach jahrzehnter langer Kontroverse
wir wollen sehen was sich seitdem hier
getan hat dafür müssen wir uns umziehen
und bekommen jeder so ein Dosimeter es
wird die Strahlenbelastung messen mal
schauen wie es dann jetzt am Ende von
meinem Besuch heute
denn auch wenn der Reaktor hinter dieser
Schleuse stillsteht ein Besuch bleibt
gefährlich
Block 2 ging vor mehr als 30 Jahren ans
Netz produzierte seitdem mehr als 375
Milliarden Kilowattstunden Strom deckte
damit jährlich ein Sechstel des
Strombedarfs von Baden-Württemberg einen
Monat nach der Abschaltung findet im
Reaktorgebäude von Block 2 keine
Kernspaltung mehr statt nach Baustelle
sieht es hier aber nicht aus
was ist denn konkret hier jetzt schon
bei ihnen passiert das wichtigste was
war war die Vorbereitung zur
Inanspruchnahme der Stilllegungen
Abbaugenehmigung formal sind wir jetzt
ja dann dort vom eigentlichen
nachbetrieb in den rechtsbetrieb
übergegangen und auch richtig im Rückbau
angekommen fürs erste heißt das die
letzten Brennelemente sind in diesem
Abklingbecken 18 Meter ist es tief das
Wasser rund 30° war es schützt vor den
hoch radioaktiven Strahlen und kühlt für
die nächsten drei bis vier Jahre so
lange wird sich hier erstmal kaum etwas
verändern denn das hören wir hier sehr
oft Weg immer sicher betrieben
im AKW geschehe kein Schritt ohne
Gutachter und behördliche Genehmigung
Behälter oder eben vorher war sind die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen die gleichen wie
eben auch zu Betriebszeiten
und das heißt alle Sicherheitsbarrieren
und alles wird so weiter vorgehalten wie
es eben zu Betriebszeiten war was später
dann passiert zeigen Videos des
Betreibers von anderen Standorten die
hauptkühlmittelleitung und werden vom
Reaktor Druckbehälter getrennt und
zerlegt der Reaktordruckbehälter
demontiert und ebenfalls zerlegt per
Fernsteuerung
sehr viel geplant werden das geht sogar
so weit dass man kompliziertere Schritte
dass man quasi inaktiv diese Dinge
nachbaut und die Verfahren die man
verwendet die schneideverfahren die
Messgeräte die fernhandierten Geräte
erst mal an inaktiven Materialien testet
bevor man sie in den aktiven Bereich
bringt um dort dann wirklich einzusetzen
aufwändig sei auch die Dekontamination
die Systeme werden von radioaktiven
Partikel befreit werden mit
Sandstrahlung oder Säure man versucht so
viel wie möglich gerade Aktivität aus
den Kreisläufen aus dem Reaktor
Druckgefäß überall alles was ich quasi
rauslösen könnte oder in diejenigen die
Luft quasi freisetzen könnte beim
Rückbau wegzukriegen solange alles
Systeme noch geschlossen sind und
funktionstüchtig sind der Weg raus aus
dem Reaktorgebäude führt uns durch
mehrere strahlenprüfungen das Ergebnis
meines dosimeters
zur Einordnung der jährliche Grenzwert
für Menschen die im AKW arbeiten bei 20
m Siebert
[Musik]
keine Kontamination ohne Kittel und
Überschuhe geht es in Richtung
Maschinenhaus wo es eins dampfte und
lernte herrscht jetzt Stille
einzelne Teile wurden hier schon
abmontiert auch die Turbine und der
Generator werden ausgebaut werden im
Block 1 von Neckarwestheim ist das schon
geschehen während das Reaktorgebäude
wegen Kontamination komplett abgebaut
wird könnte das Maschinenhaus stehen
bleiben
also wenn alle Systeme und Komponenten
hier ausgebaut sind dann ist das im
Prinzip eine große Lagerhalle das wäre
zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit
insgesamt werden beim Abbau von Block 2
800.000 Tonnen Abfall anfallen ein
Prozent davon radioaktiv also 8000
Tonnen wo die gelagert werden sehen wir
später
immer noch wird diskutiert ob man
abgeschaltete Reaktoren nicht doch noch
wieder ans Netz nehmen könnte wäre das
in der kawestheim möglich wir haben die
stilllegungs- und Abbaugenehmigung für
diesen Block erhalten und letzte Woche
auch in Anspruch genommen damit ist
unsere Betriebsgenehmigung verändert und
ohne eine Betriebsgenehmigung ist ein
Weiterbetrieb per se unmöglich aber wenn
man die Anlage einfach so lassen würde
quasi dass das Wasser bleibt drin man
dekontaminiert nicht man trifft keine
weiteren Maßnahmen für den Rückbau man
lässt alles wie gehabt könnte man
natürlich in Kernkraftwerk auch wieder
in Betrieb nehmen das Thema ist durch
wenn man eine Diskussion über den
Weiterbetrieb der Kernenergie hätte
führen wollen dann hätte man die in den
letzten Jahren führen müssen jetzt
sollten wir uns darauf konzentrieren die
Energiewende voranzubringen
uns über Jahre eigentlich da drauf
vorbereitete können also es ist für uns
nichts Überraschendes insgesamt baut die
EnBW jetzt fünf Atomkraftwerke ab und 9
Milliarden Euro wird das Kosten auf dem
Weg zum Ausgang erhaschen wir noch einen
Blick auf den Ort an dem der
kontaminierte Bauschutt demnächst landet
wir sehen hier den Eingangsbereich zum
Zwischenlager dort stehen die
Brennelemente in transport und
Lagerbehältern im allgemeinen
Sprachgebrauch Castor Behältern das ist
eine Besonderheit am Standort in
Neckarwestheim was nicht als Halle
gebaut ist sowie an den anderen
Standorten sondern als Tunnel in das
Felsgestein hinein die Ära der Atomkraft
in Neckarwestheim ist sie noch nicht
vorbei es muss immer noch ein Endlager
gefunden werden und der Rückbau des
Kraftwerks wird mindestens 15 Jahre
dauern ich fand es super spannend mal in
einem Atomkraftwerk gewesen zu sein denn
es steht fest hier wird kein Strom mehr
produziert werden auch wenn die Arbeit
hier noch längst nicht erledigt ist